bonjour katia quels sont donc les enjeux
de ce procès aux prud'hommes
les enjeux c'est bien sûr de faire
justice voilà six ans que les salariés
attendent ce moment
enfin six ans mais le procès a été
renvoyé déjà il ya deux ans à l'époque
donc en 2014 lorsque l'usiné a fermé
1134 salariés avaient été mis à la porte
alors il on avait bien multiplié les
actions coup de poing mais en pure perte
aujourd'hui ils veulent des indemnités
mais ils veulent surtout que l'on
restaure leur dignité
après des années de luttes je vous
propose d'écouter de salariés goodyear
que nous avons rencontrés à ce matin
avant l'audience
on espère vraiment qu'il soit prouvé
encore une fois parce que c'est pas la
boire avant que c'est un licenciement
abusif et on attend vraiment des
réponses et qu'on que goodyear enfin
reconnaissent que c'est que ces
licenciements abusifs
il ya deux états d'esprit est le premier
état d'esprit où tout le monde
malheureusement dans des circonstances
comme ça tout le monde se revoient et ça
c'est vraiment important pour nous ça
nous permet justement ma de prendre un
peu des nouvelles de titres différents
collègues
malheureusement il ya des collègues
qu'il n'y en a un qui viendront pu parce
que voilà ils sont sur des cd mais on
pense à eux et on se bat aussi pour eux
et puis après il ya le lot état d'esprit
ou voilà on arrive peut-être
au grand jour où justement on pourra
peut-être va poser nos valises de
bouchehr et puis passer à autre chose
n'est-ce pas qu'on a tous les goodyear
c'est que reconnaissent déjà le travail
effectué et qu'on a réalisé dans cette
usine
parce qu'il fallait être courageux pour
travailler à goodyear surtout fait
courageux pour produire jusqu'à 24 mille
peu de jours et je peux vous dire qu'il
ya pas beaucoup d'usinés en europe à
l'époque il était capable de faire ce
cette production et nous à goodyear
amiens nord on l'a réussi
vous savez quand vous arrivez à l' usine
mais juste je vais vous donner un
exemple je vous parlais des derniers
mois des dernières semaines
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui fait une
heure de route en voiture qui arrive à
l' usine qui arrive sur son poste de
travail et qui va et qui on lui donne
pas de travail
il se demande ce qu'il fait là et ça ça
a duré pendant des jours des semaines et
des mois
malgré tout on a toujours été présent on
espère et on a toujours espéré que lui
une veste ouverte n'a toujours espérer
continuer à produire
il s'avère que ça avait été décidée
certainement au lieu que on devait
fermer sept usines ont touché des des
produits nocifs
à l'époque on nous a pas dit que c'était
nocifs et je pense à tous ces gens là
qui sont tombés malades
pour certains qui est pour certains qui
en sont noirs et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
de là où j'espère que j'espère que l'on
va gagner pour eux oui donc c'est encore
une une partie encore plus tragique
bien sûr il s'agit pour aujourd'hui les
anciens salariés de d'avoir des
indemnités supplémentaires celles qui
ont été proposés par la société goodyear
étant trop faible à leur avis mais c'est
aussi un combat il y à des malades
encore aujourd'hui encore à la volée ce
matin nous entendions d'anciens salariés
parler de leur cancer actuel alors ça
fera l'objet d'un autre procès aux
etats-unis concernant les malades de
goodyear en tout cas actuellement il ya
environ six ans ancien salarié dans le
grand très grand amphithéâtre de
mégacité bien sûr un tribunal serait
beaucoup trop petit pour accueillir un
procès de cette ampleur c'est
monsieur le maître fiodor rilov qui est
actuellement en train de plaider en
train d'expliquer que la société faisait
des profits records en 2014 justement
année du licenciement de milliards 5,2
profits cette année là nous avons aussi
croiser les députés eric coquerel et
françois ruffin de la france insoumise
qui viennent accompagner soutenir les
anciens salariés dans le porte parole
s'est démenée ces dernières années
michael wamen je vous propose d'écouter
françois ruffin à ce sujet il ya six ans
en 2014 goodyear fait 2,5 milliards de
résultat net c'est son record ce même
appelle ça une explosion la
profitabilité et la même année en 2014
il décide de faire 1143 licenciement
amiens pour motif économique
comment on peut avoir un motif
économique quand il ya 2,5 milliards de
profits donc là il ya de la ces ils se
foutent de nous et le problème comment
ça se fait qu'on met six ans à juger ça
en une demi heure ça devrait être jugée
qui a pas de motif économique à ça mais
je pense qu'il faut aller au delà de ça
en vérité ce qui s'est produit c'est une
délocalisation
c'est une délocalisation de l'usiné
goodyear d'amiens vers l'usiné goodyear
a lot en pologne
pourquoi parce que là bas vous aviez un
coût du travail qui était moins cher
parce que là bas vous aviez vu de moins
faible de plus faibles normes
environnementales parce que là bas vous
étiez dans une zone franche et zéro
impôt à payer
grosso modo est donc ce qui s'est passé
c'est une délocalisation interne à
l'union européenne
donc le procès d'aujourd'hui ça devrait
être aussi le procès de l'union
européenne
2 comment on fait pour qu'on n'est pas
parce que whirlpool à amiens c'était
pareil le lave linge qui est parti vers
la slovaquie le le sèche-linge lui est
parti vers la pologne continental ces
partis vers la roumanie
parizeau siège de france est parti vers
la roumanie on peut vous faire une liste
de tas de trucs dans la région donc
c'est comment on fait pour que cette ici
si l'histoire ne se répète pas
éternellement
c'est le jour de la marmotte c'est ça ou
un mec se réveille et tous les matins
c'est le même jour qui recommence on a
l'impression d'être dans le jour de la
marmotte de l'union européenne
tous les jours il ya la même histoire
qui recommence avec une délocalisation
et qu'en plus ils veulent déguisé en
licenciement pour motif économique
mais il faut instaurer des règles pour
que ça ne se reproduise pas
éternellement et conçoit pas dans le
jour de la marmotte de l'industrie quoi
donc avec ce procès il ya un grand
espoir pour les anciens salariés goût de
goodyear de tourner enfin cette sombre
page 1 qui a laissé vraiment une
cicatrice à amiens après six ans de
combat judiciaire pour des centaines de
sa d'anciens salariés qui sont devenus
comme une famille merci à catia pour
toutes ces précisions